this garden right here it's not a great
garden but it's less in good garden
plants this rosemary is about five years
old it looks bad because it's been
around 40,000 miles in a pain in 10
degrees I know it will take 105 degrees
I know and it'll take 70 miles an hour I
found out that tomatoes don't do well
because it dropped the flowers but
peppers do fine basil does very well so
if you'll talk about tough plants I can
do it I can also plant talk about please
start some stuff like this one
I committed her beside the Coeur d'Alene
which is a terrific plant it will take
the heat it will take the win but it
won't take being baked in the back of
the truck and Mississippi so it just
collected so I had it so I'm learning
it's a learning curve okay so
horticulture I can tell you this is not
a going for a truck guard but I
continued a lot of these something
that's real notice whether where the
wind comes across the back of my throat
was no wind up against the cam when it
comes out a little bit further my toe
when you call this stuff has all the
female fan flowering y'all know the plan
oh the further gets out I can see where
the wind is because it glows all the
flowers off I drove knock out rose up
against the back of the camp and I have
to prove it a lot because it gets too
big in balloons but the pedals blow off
it's not the friendly low see I'm doing
a hold of culture thing but I'm mostly
just to show that you might accuse
garden anytime anywhere
what about winter time y'all get what 0
degrees here in the winter time we have
camellia japonica in formalin we have
paperwhites narcissist izetta just let
you know I can do that
our sister Sarah camellia japonica and
the barrage of nandina domestica in the
middle of January we have color we have
fragrance me on texture okay our down
time is right now and it's so hot you
can't move okay but in the wintertime
what do you do for guarding
entertainment what do you do well I
interviewed a fellow from here in
Cornell who found out that you can
rotate the white or census in gravel and
water these ever force daffodils to
bloom in the middle of the winter all he
needs is ground the water well I didn't
have gravel but a handsome Mardi Gras
beads you can roll paper white narcissus
in a bowl of Mardi Gras beads but
thinking about a foot the half tall is
flop over y'all know what I'm about to
talk about who's not for Middletown have
you don't know Jim in the vodka they
blow them at six or eight inches
these guys are just trying to find a way
to get through the weather Zac home I
can't talk about that you know I'm a
country that's very concerned about
rubbing out but the fact that you can
grow paperwhites indoors and milder
winter no matter how bad the weather is
no matter how blue you get in the
wintertime I think it's something that
there's precious and those are the kind
of things I try to show the simplicity
of doing easy things for the firm of it
not for the challenge other I want to
mention one last thing and by the way
Young if you go into my website find a
chance okay it is totally non profit
there are no links there are no sponsors
I do it just for the fun of it picture
me juggling balls on the front okay oh i
have a link that i put on it about slow
gardening okay slow garden now i'm going
to comment we're not slow cuz we're
stupid we're slow because where I live
we have all year to do it you think you
I mean we plant tomatoes in late March
and well I plant some more tomatoes when
i get home the first week in August I
don't plant more touch babies and more
peppers and get a harvest off of it
before our first frost we got all year
to do and if you hurry things up in the
south first of all you run out of stuff
to do you get hot that makes people
around you
it is X we should take our time who's
heard of slow food okay several things
slow food is multiple stuff growing
things locally you make good thread you
got great lettuce you have some by
Travis you make good wine let's enjoy
the things that we did locally let's get
together once the more than half of
convenient okay we call a potluck back
home okay if I bring something well it's
low guarding the same way doing things
because it's good for you checking your
own rain gauge rather than the
difference to the weather channel making
your own compost it's not that hard all
you got to do is find a place to piles
telkom our routing plans this is a
gardenia you can't grow through
gardenias here but this is a cutting
that I made about a month and a half ago
how root gardenias reach the real is our
verse of lilac okay blooms also marusan
water and I root these and give them
away all the time I read old notices the
kind of blown with no care at all we
have roses that are so tough that they
grow in cemeteries y'all got them to you
know some of the northern light series
your buck roses they
like that we have roses that will grow
on their own dream no water no sprays no
nothing to prove a point I got master
gardeners help me plan the cemetery in
between tombstones so the mower won't
get them can we prove that there are
over 40 roses of a bloater for spring
until frost and they'll care at all
these roads are the so tough that dead
people can grow on 10 people say I can't
grow roses because they get though
you've gone the wrong road that is not
Catholic y'all up here okay it's not an
heirloom rose but 150 years ago they
introduced roses that were miserable
then and they're miserable man but we've
got good roses they grow well without a
whole bunch you can these are the ones
I've try to get people started with it's
like hostas if you don't have hostas is
cause you know how many friends if you
can crack your knuckles you can
propagate hasta okay so I'm just saying
start people off the things like that
what i call comfort food plant growth
first what grows well then we're working
way up to the frustrating challenges
other thing about slow gardening is
having a party you might be hybridizing
bail is it might be inside maybe I saw
maybe have a beehive which is a cool lab
maybe start
with developing things if you have a
long take good care of attention to
detail try to work the shift those
aren't lazy or if you get them alone if
you don't want to take care of the whole
law I hope if y'all are in the meeting
this morning where you show different
ways you can treat grass you can have an
area in your landscape that is very
that's just mowed every couple of times
have a small area like a pro road like a
pudding ring but having some law that
really looks good that focus usually
issue of all these are good things to do